Halloween has begun god bless Halloween
I love it it was like full-blown
Halloween when it comes to Halloween
celebrities go all out with their
costumes
why are you trusting scary Halloween but
let's be honest sometimes they miss the
mark here's a look at the stars who gave
us more cringy than creepy we have to
start with the Diana Ross costume people
are very upset countess LuAnn from the
Real Housewives of New York said she was
just paying tribute to Diana Ross and
meant no disrespect
still she said sorry on watch what
happens live the issue is altering the
color of your skin no I did I didn't I
had bronzer on you know that I wear
normally I'm very sorry to everyone out
there if I offended anyone more
controversy for the Housewives this time
Lisa Rinna and her husband Harry Hamlin
who dressed up as Sid Vicious and his
girlfriend Nancy the problem well
Harry's costume included a swastika
t-shirt the couple issued a joint
apology on Instagram quote it hurt and
angered many of you and we are deeply
sorry for that
kif's am incognito in 2015 Pretty Little
Liars star Ashley Benson made headlines
for her costume she appeared to go as
Cecil the lion who was killed by a
big-game hunter after some backlash
online
Ashley clarified on Instagram that her
costume actually wasn't cecil and
claimed it was her management that
posted the pig she still apologized and
admitted the photo was in poor taste Kim
Kardashian got mixed reviews for
dressing up as the late singer Aaliyah
she also got flack for channeling the
late selena quintanilla some people were
offended by this couples costume worn by
Hilary Duff and former boyfriend Jason
Walsh the actress later apologized on
Twitter that could never recognize me
and that's exactly what I want to do
Heidi Klum is the undisputed queen of
Halloween but her costume in 2008 as
Hindu goddess Kali was met with some
controversy see the good thing is is
that I only had to do my face and then I
just had to like pop this on so it was
very easy buddy
I freaked myself out because I'm kind of
worried that this blue is not coming on
[Music]